[Musique]
bonsoir les débats du second tour sur tv
78 radio sensations evelyne bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez les électeurs et qui
ne sont pas parvenus à élire un maire
dès le 1er tour devront retourner aux
urnes le 28 juin prochain un scrutin du
second tour prévu initialement le 22
mars mais vous le savez reportée en
raison de l'épidémie de coronavirus ce
soir c'est un débat entre les candidats
de plaisir que nous vous proposons ne
pouvons pas les accueillir en présentiel
sur ce plateau mille sont connectés avec
nous a dit joël pris à ce niveau ce soir
tête de liste de tout à fait résolument
écologique et solidaire pour plaisir
joséphine coleman ce berger bonsoir
bonsoir maire sortante de plaisir vous
êtes la tête de liste de plaisir avance
et patrick jeantet re bonsoir bonsoir
et vous êtes-vous la tête de liste de
plaisir notre ville est notre avenir
avant de débuter ce débat le rappel des
résultats du premier tour
à plaisir et des principaux enjeux pour
la ville regard des plaisirs commune de
plus de 31 mille habitants membres de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou trois
listes seront en lice pour le second
tour des municipales
joséphine coleman ce berger maire
sortante est arrivé en tête le 15 mars
dernier devant l'ex adjoint aux finances
patrick jean terre et l'élu d'opposition
annie joël priou a signé un scrutin
juste avant le confinement où
l'abstention a atteint 63,45 % plaisir
communes ouvertes sur la plaine de
versailles partagé entre la campagne et
la ville l'aménagement du territoire
doit trouver un équilibre entre eux
urbanisation et zones naturelles
thématiques qui prend tout son sens en
cette période de crise sanitaire
l'environnement plaisir compte une forêt
plusieurs parcs naturels est la question
des transports et de la circulation se
posent encore notamment après le récent
aménagement de la rd 30 et de la
passerelle piétons cyclistes reliant la
commune à elancourt l'urbanisation c'est
la réhabilitation du centre bourg et la
rénovation du quartier du val hibou un
investissement de 65 millions d'euros
projet d'écoquartier déjà engagé que
devra poursuivre le prochain maire de la
ville avec une prise en compte plus
globale concernant la délinquance les
questions sociales et l'emploi autre
problématique la désertification
médicale la commune est classée en zone
d'action complémentaire par l' agence
régionale de santé et des médecins
approchent de la retraite risque de ne
pas être remplacés
enfin le pôle commercial va s'agrandir
avec l'ouverture prochaine d'open sky
des emplois à la clé pour les plaisirs
oit voilà pour les enjeux même si ce
débat se déroule en visio les règles ne
change pas par rapport au premier tour
les temps de parole sont chronométrées
s'afficheront régulièrement durant
l'émission
je précise que pour les premières prises
de paroles nous allons nous référer à
l'ordre d'inscription des listes que
nous a été fourni par la préfecture des
yvelines et c'est vous qui débute et
annie joël pris goût à ce ni conseillère
municipale d'opposition dans le groupe e
pepe à venir votre liste où tafer pur
plaisir est enregistré comme divers
gauche elle a le soutien du parti
socialiste et d'europe écologie les
verts et au 1er tour vous êtes classé en
troisième position avec plus de 19% des
voix
comment abordez-vous ce second tour et
est ce que le contexte actuel a changé
quelque chose dans la manière dont vous
allez aborder ce second tour
en fait taf tout à faire pour plaisir
est une une force du renouveau et elle a
montré sa différence parce que près de
20% des des plaisirs war ont voté ont
voté pour nous et je tenais à les
remercier
alors qu'est ce que ça a changé toute
façon depuis le début depuis notre
engagement nous sommes représentés par
l'écologie et la solidarité
ces deux vecteurs ce sont deux vecteurs
de notre qui forment notre identité et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire
ça a une forte résonance mais depuis le
début depuis le départ nous avons
constaté des urgences sur cette ville de
plaisir notamment pour maintenir le
l'equilibre rural urbain maintenir notre
cadre de vie et laquelle était de vider
des plaisirs wwa est également
restructuré une politique sociale et
j'englobe la politique de la jeunesse et
de la famille et joséphine coleman ce
berger vous êtes maire de plaisir depuis
2012 vous étiez auparavant adjointe au
conseil municipal et vous avez succédé à
joël regnault démissionnaire vous êtes
candidate avec la liste plaisir avance
enregistrée comme divers droite elle est
soutenu notamment par le rassemblement
yvelinois qui regroupe les fédérations
départementales de l air udi génération
terrain libre et votre candidature je le
précise est également soutenu par la
république en marche au 1er tour vous
êtes arrivé en tête avec un peu plus de
37% des suffrages même question comment
abordez-vous ce second tour et est ce
que la crise actuelle a changé quelque
chose dans la manière d'aborder cette
candidature cette nouvelle candidature
belge à bord de cette secte ce deuxième
tour avec beaucoup de d'entousiasme et
beaucoup de volonté
d'abord parce que parce que on est dans
la même dynamique c'est à dire de ce que
nous avons annoncé au premier tour c'est
à dire ce que ce que rejoint ce que
rejoignent que souhaitent les plaisirs
moi en tout cas au niveau aujourd'hui
d'une vie beaucoup plus verte mais c'est
ce qu'on a défendu depuis le départ
aujourd'hui cette deuxième set ce
deuxième tour est un tour je dirais qui
bien évidemment a été impacté par cette
période de co lead durant laquelle on a
été très présent auprès des plaisirs war
et dans une écoute très très forte de
solidarité et je tiens à remercier aussi
toutes les associations qui ont pu
participer à cette démarche là
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que une campagne
comme celle ci il doit être être une
campagne basée sur le respect en tout
cas sur le respect au niveau des
plaisirs oit moi je me vois mal en train
de faire du porte à porte aujourd'hui
avec un masque on alors je dirais faire
une intrusion auprès de la population
en tout cas ça ne nous empêche pas
d'être sur le terrain avec cette même
dynamique de volonté de cet équilibre du
rural urbain puisque nous nous sommes
engagés déjà dans notre programme que
nous avons présentés à cet équilibre là
qui est un équilibre vers bien sûr
attendu mais sans en oublier le
développement économique est quelque
chose de fondamental sur nos zones à
développer parce que l'emploi c'est
quand même la base de tout au niveau de
dan équilibre de vie
donc on est dans la même dynamique qu'au
premier tour mais avec un enthousiasme
encore plus fort puisque les plaisirs
hoarau était présent et je les remercie
patrick jean terre pour terminer ce tour
de parole premier tour de parole pendant
dix ans vous avez été adjoint de là
de plaisir en charge des finances
jusqu'en septembre 2019 vous avez décidé
avec d'autres élus de la majorité de
rejoindre l'opposition dans le groupe
ensemble avant son pur plaisir votre
liste plaisir notre ville notre avenir
est enregistré divers centres que vous
êtes arrivé deuxième au premier tour
avec 29,31 % des voix même question pour
les autres candidates
quelles perspectives pour le second tour
est ce que ça a changé les choses cette
crise sanitaire dans la manière
d'aborder ce scrutin
voyez merci je souhaite en premier lieu
à voir et vous pensez évidemment pour
toutes les familles qui ont été touchés
et puis une pensée de bien sûr de
solidarité et puis également des
félicitations pour tous ceux qui se sont
mobilisés sur le terrain tout au long de
ce confinement et que nous avons
également accompagné dans le christ soit
à titre personnel à titre collectif mais
également lorsque la ville a souhaité
nous associer sur une distribution en
basque nous avons bien sûr répondu
présent parce que c'est le rôle d'un élu
d'être auprès des habitants nous nous
présentons aujourd'hui sur ce second
tour avec nous visions peut-être un
petit peu remanié un petit peu
différente
nous avions entrevue lors du premier
tour des priorités fondamentales la
santé la solidarité l'écologie la
sécurité aussi est aujourd'hui plus que
jamais par rapport aux enjeux
économiques sociaux que nous allons
avoir dans les prochains mois il va être
très important ensemble de se battre
dans ces domaines-là en proximité auprès
des associations auprès des habitants
auprès de tous les partenaires de la
ville pour aller de l'avant et
construire un milieu être ensemble sur
notre vie pour nous et non merci
voilà pour cette introduction patrick
jeantet ray à nice jouait le prix où est
né vous êtes autour d une minute détente
de temps de parole pour commencer vous
avez un peu plus avant joséphine coleman
aux bergers avec une minute et quarante
et une secondes alors pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous avait suivi au
premier tour et nous n'avions pas eu le
temps là des refus d'aborder la
thématique de la solidarité nous avons
donc choisi de commencer par cette
thématique aujourd'hui une thématique on
le sait un qui prend tout son sens dans
le contexte actuel où est la crise
touche de plein fouet les entreprises
mais aussi les particuliers
la solidarité vous en parlait d'ailleurs
coûté toussaint dans vos programmes
respectifs quand on regarde vos
propositions en la matière et notamment
celle de créer recréer du lien entre les
quartiers entre les différentes
générations
comment y parvenir annie joël pris aux
as mis une proposition de votre part
dans notre programme c'est celle par
exemple de créer une maison citoyenne
aussi d'associer les plaisirs wa
davantage dans les commissions
municipales c'est quelques unes de vos
propositions
oui c'est tout à fait ça c'est vrai déjà
la solidarité c'est un terme très
positif en soi c'est se construire avec
les autres donc on a vu notamment lors
de la crise
on est encore dans cette crise sanitaire
mais au moment du confinement
il y avait beaucoup de solidarité chez
les plaisirs aux as et notamment grâce à
ce tissu associatif à plaisir on compte
un nombre important d'associations que
ce soit de social et culturel du sportif
aussi mais ce qui manque ce sont les
liens venez de le dire
vous voulez vous venez de souligner le
problème donc qu'il faut renforcer ce
lien et la municipalité de voir un rôle
là dedans donc effectivement nous
proposons des maisons citoyennes qui se
retrouve dans tous les quartiers et dans
tous les lieux de la ville où on en a
besoin
où le besoin se fait sentir et mon
regroupe en fait des permanences des
services des services de la ville des
services publics est également une
assistance sociale des services sociaux
et également des activités sociales
culturelles activités physiques et de
bien-être également donc on regroupe
tout ça dans une dans une maison
citoyenne
ça permet en fait de savez le fait de
décentrer les services permet de
de mettre au centre le plaisir oil
habitants à plaisir voilà et ses dents
il faut en fait renforcée aussi cet
esprit de quartier cet esprit de vie
parce que et notamment en passant par
par la jeunesse en restructurant une
véritable service social de jeunesse en
permettant aux jeunes de se retrouver
dans des clubs dans dans des activités
ouvrir les stades les équipements
sportifs et éviter aussi que cette
jeunesse partent ailleurs et quitte
plaisir on recrée aussi une articulation
entre l'emploi les l'offre d'emploi et
la jeunesse et ça passe par l'école et
ça passe par les études et l'université
voilà donc où la fête on englobe toute
cette politique familiale et de la
jeunesse au sein de la solidarité
comment créer patridge inter entretenir
le lien social
alors vous souhaitez par exemple vont
intégrer aussi la démocratie
participative en sollicitant les
habitants sur des référendum pour
décider de certains projets sur la ville
de plaisir oui alors la solidarité
effectivement comme vous le mentionnez
elle a de multiples visages et elle nous
souhaitons renforcer ce lien qui a pu
être perdu à différents titres ces
dernières années l'un des axes que nous
souhaitons développer évidemment c'est
la démocratie participative mettre en
place des vrais conseils de quartier
avec qui nous allons décider pour
construire ensemble la ville de demain
et gérer le quotidien
véritablement de ces quartiers que ce
soit en terme de voirie de sécurité
d'animation etc
ça c'est un des axes et au travers de
ses conseils de quartier nous viendrons
très régulièrement avec les habitants
envisager ensemble comment améliorer la
vie dans les quartiers mais aussi dans
la ville un autre axe ça va être
effectivement à la fois les associations
l'éducation la médiation c'est un axe
très important nos associations sont un
lien formidable incroyable à travers la
ville nous souhaitons renforcer ce lien
à la fois en matière financière mais
aussi logistique davantage chute de près
de 5 d accompagnement administratif ou
en termes de gestion et c'est du sport
libre des scènes libres pour arriver à
ouvrir davantage la culture le sport et
l'esprit site
un dans la ville notre axe effectivement
dont je parle et c'est la médiation les
éducateurs de rue les médiateurs qu'il
va falloir renforcer nous dire bon
projet de doubler la mosaïque qui est
une une institution incroyablement bien
situé au carrefour de plusieurs
quartiers et que nous souhaitons
davantage effectivement développer dans
les prochaines années
enfin le dernier lien qui n'est pas à
négliger en matière de solidarité c'est
le petit commerce
nos entreprises tous nos acteurs de
proximité qui eux aussi contribuer à au
bien-être contribuer au rayonnement de
la ville et vont être en difficulté dans
les prochains mois les prochaines années
donc il va falloir être effectivement
auprès de la population auprès des
différents acteurs des associations et
de nos entreprises avec un programme de
proximité des services de proximité
mais joséphine coleman de l'argent va
vous laisser répondre juste précisé que
l'un des quatre axes de votre campagne
c'est la ville humaine impliqué aussi un
les habitants dans les projets de la
ville les accompagner dans chaque étape
de la vie sont quelques-unes des
promesses de campagne ça c'est utile oui
pour créer et entretenir le lien social
à plaisir je tenais déjà remercier mes
collègues de rappeler que nous avons
effectivement un tissu associatif très
fort sur la vie de plaisirs qui
fonctionne très très bien depuis de
nombreuses années et avec lesquels nous
avons de vrais partenariats les remercie
également de rappeler que nous avons des
maisons des familles les maisons des
familles sont aussi des lieux qu'il
existe aujourd'hui sur la collectivité
avec qui nous avons énormément de
projets qui sont en développement
également nous avons dans le projet
aussi un conseil de développement qui
est justement la participation citoyenne
de tous les habitants que nous faisons
depuis de nombreuses années je suis
assez étonné que monsieur l'inter qui a
été à mes côtés pendant de si longues
années et oublier que nous avons mis en
place les médiateurs pour lesquels
d'ailleurs il n'était pas d'accord à une
certaine période
donc j'en suis ravi de voir qu'il ne
considère que les médiateurs sont
indispensables sur la collectivité
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans cette dans
ce développement là qui sont je dirais
des choses déjà très bien implanté sur
la collectivité qui ne sont pas
parfaites je le reconnais c'est
compliqué il faut pas oublier que nous
sommes aussi dans une période très
complexe au niveau financier toutes les
collectes
bt ont des difficultés et nous devons en
bon père de famille ou mères de famille
gérer aussi en fonction je dirais que du
développement et des attentes
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ce conseil de développement
que nous voulons mettre en place
et justement un lien avec les quartiers
et avec entre guillemets des
ambassadeurs de quartier liait avec nos
adjoints et nos conseillers pour pouvoir
travailler dans une écoute et dans un
développement en lien direct avec la
population que nous faisons déjà
donc je vais pas dire que nous ne sommes
pas dans un développement je dis
simplement que je suis ravi d'entendre
que malgré tout on se rend compte que
sur plaisir il ya énormément de choses
qui sont faites et que aujourd'hui nous
devons ensemble bien sûr les améliorer
et les développer j'aimerais juste vous
en tendant un instant sur la thématique
de l'emploi un qui est liée à celle de
la solidarité peut être déjà un autre
tour de table vous êtes tous je le
précise aux alentours de trois minutes
de temps de parole trois minutes et 33
secondes exactement pour joséphine
coleman berger a ni jo est pris aux
aciers c'est ce que vous souhaitez
ajouter quelque chose sur cette
thématique peut être répondre à ce qui a
été dit rebondir sur ce qui a été dit
oui merci oui oui alors madame comme à
ce berger effectivement il existe des
maisons les appeler maintenant les
familles que vous accompagner chaque
habitant jeu alors là je suis un petit
peu surprise parce que nous rencontrons
les habitants et effectivement il manque
vraiment d'accompagnement il manque
d'information il manque de transparence
et souvent c'est plutôt des doléances
que nous recevons en ce qui concerne les
maisons des familles c'est pas tout à
fait les maisons citoyennes
effectivement ce sont des maisons voilà
on sort au goût plusieurs activités mais
on y rajoute quand même des permanences
avec une assistance sociale ce qui n'ont
vraiment cruellement à plaisir le
recrutement d'une assistance sociale ici
pour la jeunesse et pour les familles
qui en ont besoin est
et vous parlez des médiateurs oui alors
oui mais historiquement on revient un
petit peu en arrière vous
avait quand même chassé les équipes de
juger les éducateurs spécialisés les
éducateurs de rue qui permettait
justement cette prévention que nous
n'avons plus aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
plus de moyens on ne donnait pas
suffisamment moyens parce que vous
répondez toujours en fonction du budget
nous ce que l'on veut c'est répondre aux
besoins et adapter les moyens c'est une
politique totalement différente de la
vôtre est notamment très citoyenne voilà
patrick g intérêt on voulait fera
répondre joséphine calme ce merdier
juste ça presse oui je vous remercie
une petite précision où je n'ai jamais
été contre le médiateur contrairement à
ce que dit madame le maire c'est un un
moyen de proximité d'être auprès de nos
jeunes que ce soit les médiateurs les
éducateurs de rue les assistantes
sociales
c'est quelque chose qui va être de plus
en plus important devant nous de
développer davantage et dément
aujourd'hui on l'exprimé des clubs à dos
il va falloir remettre des structures en
proximité de nos ados de nos jeunes pour
les accompagner nous allons au devant de
pertes d'emplois massives
il va falloir au contraire renforcer ce
lien aider les jeunes à revenir en reste
là contre réinsertion à redon en
recherche de stage en recherche d'emploi
et au delà du manque de l'expérience que
l'on a pu acquis accueillir des erreurs
commises recherche effectivement les
idées les bonnes idées chez nous chez
les autres qui fonctionne pour apporter
effectivement ce lien j'ai parlé des
jeunes il faut parler également des
seniors il faut parler aussi du handicap
quelque chose qui a été 3 sous-évalué
trop mal soutenu ces dernières années
les aidants familiaux en particulier en
pratique nous devons avoir une action
vraiment de proximité une action
soutenue pour accompagner nos familles
pour accompagner nos seniors et pour
accompagner bien sûr toutes les
générations dans les mois les années qui
viennent parce que ça va être compliqué
et c'est là où les luttes à joséphine
pas le manque d'argent une minute à peu
près si on veut avoir le temps de parler
d'emploi juste après quelques éléments
de réponse à apporter
je ne peux que vous rejoins sur le fait
que dans les mois qui viennent et les
amis qui viennent les choses seront
difficiles à deux le sont déjà
nous le savons au niveau des jeunes un
bijou va être mis en place un bureau
pour les jeunes
d'information dans le cadre des
créations de tout ce qui est en cours
aujourd'hui sur le vavi bout puisqu'il
va y avoir aussi une salle associative
supplémentaire en plus du ccas et de la
pmi qui vont être construits dans le
cadre du vélib ou d'un geste important
pour ce qui est des seniors mais savait
que nous avons 1600 seniors qui sont
inscrits à la maison rousseau et durant
la période du coc vide
nous avons été très très proche des
seniors je ne pense pas aujourd'hui que
vous puissiez émettre quelques réserves
sur ce sujet puisque nous avons appelé
tous les seniors par rapport à cette
période et nous sommes en proximité avec
eux de façon permanente maintenant la
solidarité vous avez raison elle va bien
au-delà de ce que vous avez évoqué de ce
que nous évoquions ensemble et c'est
très étrange parce que nous sommes plus
ou moins d'accord en tout cas sur pas
mal de sujets et sur la chose peut être
que vous ne connaissez pas suffisamment
qui sont déjà mises en place sur la
ville et j'en suis désolé parce que je
peux vous dire que nos services
travaillent d'arrache-pied et fortement
et la vie de plaisirs et quand même une
ville reconnue comme étant vive
solidaire et c'est pas simplement un
label que nous avons eu l'idée de
l'europe
pardon c'est un véritable label d'action
avec 90 associations solidaires avec
nous sur l'aide sociale
et puis je ferai le lien mais puisque
vous avez faire avec le commerce nous
avons bien sûr enclenché tout une
démarche auprès des commerces de
proximité et des grandes entreprises par
rapport à cette suite de qu'ovide mais
je vous redonne la parole excusez moi
d'avoir enchaîné là dessus bien sûr nous
avons fait beaucoup de choses par
rapport à cela aussi
avant de parler effectivement la
deuxième thématique qui sera consacré à
la santé je voulais vous entendre sur
celle de l'emploi un forcément liées à
la solidarité d'autant que la crise
sanitaire c'est mieux aujourd'hui en
crise économique les derniers chiffres
de l'emploi sous catastrophique la
france à a connu une hausse record du
chômage en avril à plaisir notamment il
ya le quartier du val ibuki est touché
par cette problématique du chômage
je voudrais vous entendre sur les
leviers quels sont les leviers que peut
avoir le maire pour contrer à l'échelle
de la ville ce chômage a nié jouer le
prix du sms
oui et bien déjà rendre la ville plus
attractive
pour que les entreprises les petites
entreprises et les commerces viennent
s'installer aussi à plaisir il manque
cruellement de d'emplacement et de
structures aussi pour les accueillir et
dans vie de venir ici
il faut absolument déployer l'emploi ici
à plaisir pour que d'ailleurs notamment
les jeunes puissent travailler à plaisir
et que les plaisirs aussi puissent
travailler à plaisir nous sommes
toujours contraints de prendre les
transports et de prendre quand on enlève
la voiture aussi pour aller travailler
donc il faut amener et ramener les
entreprises ici et pour ça il ya une
forme d'acte d'attractivité qui doit se
faire si mon âge je déborde sur la santé
mais enfin plutôt la santé puis
l'environnement il y a des terrains
entre l'ancien hôpital charcot et bien
c'est le moment ou jamais de permettre à
cet emplacement de recréer une dynamique
au niveau de l'emploi des petits
commerces et des petites constructions
aussi qu'ils sont qui correspondent au
cadre de vie
voilà donc il ya toute une
restructuration à faire au niveau de la
ville pour l'emploi bien sûr quels sont
les leviers patridge inter que dont peut
disposer le maire pour agir pour
l'emploi au niveau d'une d'une commune
d'une ville va y avoir différents axes
effectivement d'abord accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi les chercheurs
d'emploi qu'ils soient jeunes ou moins
jeunes
on oublie souvent qu'il n'ya pas
effectivement que les jeunes qui sont
touchés par le chômage mais également
les les quadras les gars cas pour
lesquels le taux de chômage est
particulièrement élevé en france
structurellement parlant et qu'il faut
pouvoir accompagner
il ya un certain nombre de mesures à
faire d'abord l'accompagnement au
quotidien en proximité 20 jan tout à
l'heure au travers de la mosaïque et
d'autres instances comme la noue la
maison de l'entreprise et de l'emploi
donc tout ça c'est en partenariat aussi
avec d'autres structures intercommunales
ou nationale c'est aussi un
accompagnement au quotidien au travers
des éducateurs au travers des services
de proximité pour apprendre aux
personnes à faire un suivi à rechercher
un emploi à reprendre confiance
tout simplement est en train c'est un
axe qui va être concernant les tpe les
pme le commerce de proximité contribué à
développer notre marché contribuent à
développer des circuits courts qui rompt
du maraîchage de proximité bio jusqu'à
la transformation et jusqu'à la vente en
proximité des pôles technologiques ou
des halls d'innovation qu'ils peuvent
être installés sur la ville comme ça
soit sur la zone de ste apolline où la
structure zone de sharp au don ma
collègue a parlé il ya un instant pour
installer des start up des jeunes
entreprises dans la ligue santé dans
l'environnement ou pourquoi pas dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire
voilà des moyens un maire des élus une
ville effectivement peu à voir demain
pour contribuer à la création d'emploi
et la création d'activités
je vous ai pink alma de vergers que peut
faire le maire oui sur 7 sur 7
thématiques de l'emploi
que fait le maire déjà on pourrait dire
puisque on a déjà la maison de
l'entreprise de l'emploi qui accompagne
effectivement les jeunes déjà et les
moins jeunes comme disait monsieur
l'inter puisque c'est ouvert à tous les
âges
mais il y a aussi des actions concrètes
qui sont faites d'accompagnement on a
des actions qui sont actuellement en
développement comme un trek que l'on
organise régulièrement en irlande pour
remettre des jeunes sur sur la confiance
en soi il n'ya pas uniquement ça on a
aussi accompagné suite au vide les
entreprises
on les a toutes appelées les unes après
les autres puisque un plaisir me savais
que nous avons un nombre d'entreprises
très important nous ne sommes pas dans
une désertification ans au sein de la
ville des entreprises nous sommes au
contraire dans un développement puisque
la zone de saint-apollinaire la zone des
gâtines a depuis plusieurs années est
rentré dans une réflexion qui est la
réflexion de la zone high-tech et qui
est une réflexion qui trie qui est en
plein travail avec 50 arrivée pour
devenir des lieux d'excellence pour
justement développer davantage encore
l'emploi n'oublions pas que openskies ne
serait-ce qu open sky et nous avons
formulé avec une convention pour
embaucher prioritairement des jeunes il
y a eu 450 emplois et toutes les
entreprises qui s'installent sur plaisir
nous travaillons avec eux pour des
conventionnements justement
pour mettre des jeunes dans l' embauche
prioritaire donc tout ça ce sont des
axes importants que nous faisons déjà et
qui sont des axes d'accompagnement aussi
financier puisqu'elle ne serait-ce qu'
il y a quelques jours au conseil
municipal nous avons voté une baisse de
la pnp eux c'est à dire la taxe sur les
enseignes pour pouvoir les accompagner
et en tant que vice-présidente au
département il ya 50 1 je m'emploie
justement avec la mission de l'emploi de
travailler avec eux pour pouvoir
accompagner non seulement les
entreprises dans leurs difficultés
financières d'aujourd'hui mais aussi
dans des développements qui est
aujourd'hui indispensable pour les
jeunes qui rentrent sur le marché
regardons tout de suite les chronomètres
joséphine coleman berger et vous avez de
la vence sept minutes 39 de temps de
parole patrick jean terre six minutes
annie joël prix os ni vous êtes un petit
peu en retard avec cinq minutes 30
mais on aura l'occasion de rattraper ce
temps de retard avec la deuxième
thématique de ce débat un sur tv 78 et
radio sensations yvelines un vous nous
écoutez également sur le 98 points 4 on
parle à présent santé sujet d'importance
mêmes qui prend une autre dimension en
ce moment plaisir est classé par l'
agence régionale de santé en zone
d'action complémentaires plusieurs
médecins généralistes sont proches de la
retraite et risque est de ne pas être
remplacés alors comment éviter un
phénomène de désertification médicale
dans une ville qui je le précise a aussi
un sur son sol un centre hospitalier a
dédié à la santé mentale à la gériatrie
et au médico social on a parlé
longuement sur ce plateau au premier
tour de projet de maison médicale que
vous avez tous dans vos programmes très
rapidement joséphine coleman vers dieu
parce que vous êtes en avance sur le
temps de parole vous nous parliez d'un
projet qui est déjà prêt qui serait
financée par le département
si vous être élu ce que vous êtes en
capacité d'ouvrir cette maison médicale
est est-ce qu'il y aurait des médecins à
mettre dedans parce que là si la
question aussi importante à se poser
c'est est ce qu'il ya des médecins de
disponible pour cette cette maison
médicale
mais je peux vous l'affirmer nous avons
trois médecins qui arrivent dans la
structure qui s'appelle la ruche qui est
la structure intermédiaire est installé
dans l'hôpital aujourd'hui du centre
hospitalier de plaisir et qui ensuite
intégrera avec des médecins
supplémentaire est dû
médicales le fameux bâtiment qui va être
construit par le département des
yvelines
donc on est aujourd'hui en mesure de
vous affirmer que nous avons non
seulement les trois médecins pour la rue
mais également d'autres médecins qui
vont arriver en octobre novembre sur des
travaux qui sont en cours à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
et donc aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans
un développement positif avec des
médecins qui ont été trouvés et donc
j'en suis ravi et je suis ravi de vous
l'annoncer
alors puisque la première si je le
rappelle un qui a été soulevée sur ce
plateau au premier tour c'est celle de
comment attirer les médecins comment les
retenir aussi à plaisir les faire rester
dans la ville annie joël prix ou hasseni
l'une des solutions que vous évoquez
dans votre programme c'est davantage
développer les partenariats avec
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines est ce que ça c'est une
solution pour attirer de jeunes médecins
leur facilité peut-être l'installation à
plaisir oui bien sûr c'est qu'une
solution il faut passer par des
relations partenariales avec la rs le
mental de leurs données de st les
syndicats étudiants et c'est bien sûr
mais bon madame comme un berger dit
qu'il ya trois médecins qui arrivent ils
arrivent quand d'abord je faire savoir
et les autres en octobre novembre ce
sont des généralistes je suis poli oui
on est bien mais ça a quand même ça fait
plusieurs années que nous sommes en
manque
on était en était à quatre généralistes
pratiquement quatre généralistes pour
10000 habitants sur plaisir en dessous
du seuil même minimum en ile de france
donc nous on voulait absolument et on
veut toujours lancer un plan d'urgence
parce que effectivement c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure nous allons
avoir des médecins
tant mieux on a attendu quatre ans enfin
tant mieux mais ils m'ont quand même des
cardiologues il ya le nombre de kiné qui
manque furieusement donc il manque aussi
des professionnels de santé et il faut
pouvoir les retenir c'est exactement ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
donc il faut redynamiser plaisir en
termes de santé et la municipalité a
aussi ce rôle
il faut attirer les médecins et les
professionnels de santé et pour ça il
faut prôner les attirer dans une zone
qui sous médicalisées parce que même
avec trois médecins ou quelques-uns puce
on va rester sous médicalisées donc il
faut pouvoir les comprendre comprendre
leurs besoins les attentes disons qu'il
ya énormément évolué ce sont des
médecins qui ont besoin d'être salarié
maintenant qui veulent travailler en
équipe
il faut aussi les pouvoirs les
accompagnent et donc les décharger des
des tâches administratives
je sais pas si c'est prévu mais en tout
cas qu'il y ait une secrétaire médicale
qui sont recrutés par la municipalité ou
une assistante médicale pour les seconds
et voilà donc on a besoin de
retravailler
tous ces phénomènes qui sont très
importants et puis ça ne suffit pas
parce que les maisons médicalisées avec
des médecins d'accord pourquoi pas oui
on en a besoin mais il faut aussi que
alors on parlait tout à l'heure
justement de remettre l'habitant au
centre décision il n'existe pas une
commission municipale de santé de
handicap à plaisir donc nous dès qu'on
est élu on la met en place et vous aurez
des habitants qui ont des associations
qui représentent justement des des
personnes handicapées et des patients
aussi qu'ils pourront intégrer ces
commissions et qui se seront partie
prenante dans les décisions et il faut
de la prévention et pour ça ça passe par
un discours un déploiement au niveau des
collèges et lycées des conférences que
plaisir soit vraiment devenue attractive
aussi pour les médecins et les
professionnels de santé
alors patrick chanteur une idée qui a
été soulevée celle par exemple de
salariés les médecins en tout cas ça
c'est aussi l'une de vos idées dans
votre programme les déchargé des tâches
administratives
est ce qu'en termes de budget pour une
ville est ce que c'est possible
aujourd'hui de salariés les médecins car
nous avons identifié les travailler très
tôt sur sur cette thématique nous avons
entre les différents pharmaciens et
médecins de la ville qui pendant des
années ne se sont pas sentis écoutés
voire même laissés pour compte alors qu
il alerté sur cette problématique
départ un certain nombre de médecins
sont pas allés loin sont allés dans les
villes à côté le plaisir n'a pas répondu
à leur demande nous projetons
effectivement très rapidement de m un
des bâtiments municipaux à disposition
pour quatre médecins qui ont déjà à
toquer à la porte qui sont prêts à nous
rejoindre soit en libéral soit enfin
variables comme vous le mentionnez avec
effectivement un accompagnement de
services clés en main secrétariat
comptabilité prise de rendez-vous ménage
entretien etc et faire de ces maisons
médicales d'abord dans un bâtiment
existant dès demain dans un bâtiment que
nous construirons un bâtiment municipal
sur lequel la ville s'engagera au
travers d'une fille qui s'appelle une
sem société d'économie mixte et qui
permettra d'équilibrer parce que lorsque
l'on regarde comment fonctionne d'autres
villes sur le même genre de projet ce
sont des budgets qui finissent à
s'équilibrer avec le temps donc c'est
tout à fait possible d'investir sur une
maison médicale de permettre à
différents praticiens et en particulier
des médecins généralistes
puis des pédiatres des ophtalmologistes
des cardiologues qui vient autour des
kinés des infirmières etc
et pourquoi pas accompagnée ces maisons
médicales avec des espaces de coworking
pour faciliter le contact avec des start
up dans le monde de la e-santé dans le
monde de la télé consultation de
proximité avec les pharmaciens de
secteur et enfin le dernier point qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que pour venir
dans sa maison médicale
il faut pouvoir se déplacer aujourd'hui
on a une vraie problématique avec mon
bus nos transports en commun sur la
ville
c'est pour ça que nous proposons très
rapidement de mettre en place des
navettes interquartiers propres ce qui
répondra à la fois une problématique
écologique mais aussi une problématique
de famille de seniors de personnes
handicapées ou tout simplement venir à
leur rendez vous médical ou aller faire
leurs courses
tout ça c'est très lié et c'est francine
global moi je sais qu'une telle mesure
j'ai pour terminer ce tour de parole on
vous indiquant que malheureusement on
n'aura pas le temps d'aborder la
dernière thématique et l'environnement
mais je renvoie les téléspectateurs et
les auditeurs à revoir à nouveau le
débat du premier tour où 7 thématiques
avait été largement abordés on a eu
comme ça le temps d'aborder cette
thématique de la solidarité de la santé
joséphine coleman berger est ce que
salarié les médecins oui effectivement
ça peut être une
une solution pour pour retenir les
médecins dans une ville effectivement au
niveau des médecins
il ya beaucoup de choses encore une fois
que vous ne savez pas et j'en suis
désolé
puisque le travail avec l'université est
en cours depuis pas mal d'années et
c'est une vraie complexité pour les
jeunes étudiants aujourd'hui vous le
savez et puis au niveau de l'hôpital
c'est un travail aussi que nous faisons
de façon permanente avec eux justement
pour trouver cette 7e cette possibilité
aux médecins de venir s'y installer
alors au niveau de dudus de salariés et
les médecins c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas forcément demandé
par les médecins c'est c'est quelque
chose qui a été proposé dans les zones
rurales
mais en zone urbaine c'est pas que c'est
pas quelque chose qui est fondamentale
en tout cas pour laisser revenir les
faire venir c'est un accompagnement
administratif ce sont des lieux adéquate
et les lieux adéquate dans le centre
hospitalier par exemple comme plaisir
c'est parfait puisqu'il ya effectivement
déjà des bureaux de l'administratif qui
va être mis en place par le département
il y a aussi toute une série de 2 peu de
situations je dirais d'accompagnement
comme le scanner comme tout ce qui est
mis en place l'irm aujourd'hui au niveau
de l'hôpital
et puis aussi des aménagements nouveaux
qui vont être faits dans cet hôpital en
vue justement de cet accompagnement de
ces maisons là aujourd'hui bien sûr ce
n'est pas ce ne sont pas que des
généralistes qui vont revenir sur
plaisir ce sont aussi des spécialistes
est aussi d'équipé puisque aujourd'hui
va y avoir aussi tout un aménagement
pour les kinés aujourd'hui au niveau de
au sein de l'hôpital donc nous sommes
dans cette démarche là et c'est vrai
madame clio à ce niveau vous dites ça
fait quatre ans mais c'est très
compliqué vous savez à trouver je peux
vous dire que c'est pas si ça c'est
facile d'annoncer des choses en disant
voilà on va faire si on va faire ça mais
quand on est dans l'action je peux vous
dire que les choses ne sont pas si
simples et vous le savez je ne je vous
dis que on a vraiment fait un maximum
on va laisser et on est satisfait on va
laisser répondre même priorité monsieur
jean terre sur cette situation
sur ce thème pour le clôturer une minute
vraiment chacun pour qu'on puisse avoir
après quelques minutes de
conclusion pour terminer ce débat annie
joël prix us ni si vous souhaitez
ajouter quelque chose peut être répondre
à ce que vient de dire joseph il colmate
vergers ont une minute je vous en
remercie et bien juste vous dites
souvent madame commerce berger que on
fait ceci on fait cela on va faire ceci
ou à faire cela mais finalement je me
pose toujours la question mais c'est pas
la première fois pourquoi vous l'avez
pas fait plus tôt
il ya quatre ans vous avez eu
effectivement les pharmaciens et les
médecins qui sont nous dans votre bureau
qui vous ont dit qu'ils me sonne l
alarme qui vous ont dit on il va y avoir
une désertification médicale et vous
n'avez rien fait donc map assez légères
et c'est moi qui les ai invités à venir
en réunion madame priori pardon avant
ils avaient ils vous avaient alerté
quand même monsieur jean terre pour
terminer sur cette thématique de la
santé
oui je ne reprendrais j'accompagne ma
collègue prions ce n'est effectivement
la verte est venu bien plus tôt il ya
des choses urgentes à faire et des jours
ci des choses structurelles sur lesquels
nous souhaitons investir nous l'avons
dit je m'inscris en faux par rapport au
salariat des médecins c'est une vraie
demande y compris pour les médecins de
nouvelle génération qui veulent
travailler deux fois par semaine par
exemple et qui ne souhaitent plus en
iran libera donc il faut regarder toutes
les solutions possibles toute l'ampleur
des solutions possibles pour faire venir
ces praticiens ses médecins généralistes
et les différents spécialistes autour
d'eux est donc construit avoir un projet
qui soit vu avec sa globalité et
surprend à proximité des habitants coup
d'oeil une dernière fois sur sur les
chronomètres neuf minutes 57 pour
joséphine coleman berger patrick jeantet
huit minutes 48 annie jouer le prix ou
hasseni huit minutes 57 pour la
conclusion va prendre le sens inverse
là des premières prises de paroles c'est
à dire que c'est vous patridge inter qui
allait reprendre la parole pour terminer
ce débat libre à vous d'aborder une
thématique libre peut être de préciser
une autre thématique étaient abordés au
cours de ce débat où vous dire
simplement quelques mots de conclusion
vous avez deux minutes il faut il faut
pas dépasser ces deux minutes voilà oui
merci effectivement on va tenter de
faire cours sur quelques points
importants rappeler qu'au premier tour
près des deux tiers plus des deux tiers
des plaisirs war en manifester la
volonté d'un changement d'un changement
positive et nous ont placé le nantais
comme sorte d'alternative capable
d'amener un nouveau projet pour la ville
ce projet il est basé sur différentes
valeurs la solidarité la santé
l'écologie la sexualité la proximité en
particulier au travers des différentes
thématiques que nous allons c'est
important ça permettra demain de
construire la ville que nous souhaitons
une ville où il fait bon vivre une file
qui protège son environnement
une ville qui rayonne qui prépare son
avenir une femme une liste 100% plaisir
aux as nous habitons nous vivons nous
aimons notre ville
tous ensemble toutes ces petits plaisirs
notre vie de notre avenir est
majoritairement des gens engagés dans le
monde associatif parlement de citoyens
sportifs ou culturels
et ce sont ces valeurs cette expérience
ses compétences que nous souhaitons à
portée de main avec un engagement un
engagement fort au service des plaisirs
war au service de la vie si vous le
faites et vous avez encore 30 secondes
pour équilibrer les temps de parole
patridge inter oui bah c'est une vision
d'avenir pour propose ici c'est à dire
une ville plus solidaire une ville plus
écologique une ville qui est neuf
si j'ai parlé tout à l'heure des
startups en matière de e-santé
d'économie sociale et solidaire en
matière d'écologie de maraîchage des
jeunes entreprises des petits commerces
et des associations qui demain
construire en un tissu solidaire pour
améliorer la ville et pour améliorer son
avenir je définis quand le maître verges
en 30 secondes pour pour terminer je
sais bien que je reste sur les grandes
lignes qui sont les lignes de que nous
avions engagés c'est à dire tout d'abord
avoir une équipe fiable une équipe
engagée une équipe je dirais rajeuni
également dansé dans son envie aidant et
en cédant ses projets avec une vie la
nature une ville durable qui nous semble
important aujourd'hui ça a été encore
plus demandés c'étaient les premières
choses que nous souhaitons une ville
humaine parce que ça nous semble aussi
important parler de solidarité tout à
leur protectrice entreprenante
on a scié de plaisir une ville
ambitieuse elle l'est aujourd'hui
l'emploi n'est pas si mauvais que cela
plaisir bien au contraire est une ville
responsable et surtout une ville
respectueuse
voilà qui jouait le prix
hasseni une minute trente pour vous pour
conclure ce débat est bien ce que je
disais au départ au début
tav tout à faire pour plaisir est une
force
on s'est imposé dans le paysage
politique de la ville nous sommes
présents au second tour est vraiment
l'équipe qui est auprès de moi
on a vraiment construit cette envie de
changer la ville de rencontres avec les
plaisirs war on a senti vraiment des
besoins très fort d'être au centre de
ces décisions
les décisions doivent être discutées
elles doivent pas être imposée est bien
sûr la vision que nous avons de la ville
c'est qu'elles puissent nous apporter
tout le bien-être dont nous avons besoin
surtout en ce moment et surtout à la
rentrée parce qu'il ya des inquiétudes
pour la rentrée en septembre
donc on peut apporter tous ces plans
d'urgence qui me semble vraiment très
importants et notamment son
environnement n'en a pas parlé pour
permettre un cadre de vie qualité de vie
ou aux plaisirs war et notamment
constaté le manque de mobilité douce
même si elles sont un peu temporaire
faire des mobilités 12 et circulations
douces sécurisée et en continu même
s'ils sont temporaires elles peuvent
devenir pérenne et pour le stationnement
vraiment met aussi un plan d'urgence que
ce ça va pas du tout voilà pour
l'environnement aje renvoie une dernière
fois les téléspectateurs les auditeurs à
revoir le premier débat celui du premier
tour pour la ville de plaisir dernier
coup d'oeil aux temps de parole vous
êtes tous aux alentours des 10 minutes
10 minutes 30 pour cette émission et ce
débat qui touche à sa fin merci à vous
trois d'y avoir participé
le débat je précise qu'il est à
retrouver en replay sur tv 78 points
comme est également podcast audio 1 chez
nos confrères de radio sensations
yvelines second tour des municipales
au programme pour rappel le dimanche 28
juin et les débats du scrutin de ce
second tour continue sur tv 78 radio
sensations et vu une belle soirée à tous
[Musique]